identify all the rays shown in the image
below and just as a reminder what array
is array starts at some point and then
goes on forever in some direction in
order to find array you need that point
that you're starting off on so let's say
that point right over there is called x
and then you need another point that
sits on the ray but the rays just going
to go keep going past it so let's say
that that is y over here then we would
label this ray we would call it ray x
not x x we would rate we would label it
x y
and this it says it starts at x so it's
starting at x and it keeps on going
forever in the direction of y it goes
towards y and then passes y and then
just keeps on going and you need the
second point and you need the second
point essentially to specify the
direction we're going starting an x in
the direction of y going meeting y then
going beyond y so with that out of the
way let's identify all the rays shown in
the image below
so we can start well we can start really
anywhere over here well let's start over
here at point j point j we have no array
the only ray that we have or any the
only line that's really we have or line
segment from j is going straight up
towards h and then it goes towards h and
it keeps on going so this right over
here looks like a ray and it would be
ray j h
ray j h we we're starting at j
going through h and then we just keep on
going forever
now if you go to point h there is no ray
h j
because j the line ends at j doesn't
keep on going forever so there is no ray
h j and there is no ray h because just
with one point you're not specifying
array you're not specifying the
direction you might be tempted to say
that this is a ray but there's no point
over here to help specify the direction
so just using this one point you can't
say that this ray is starting right over
there so looking at this part of our
diagram right over here the only ray the
only ray is jh
now let's look at the other points so
that is jh
if we look at point c once again you
might want to create a ray that goes
here to the right but there's no other
point to specify the direction so we're
going to go in the other direction so
you could have a ray called ce starts at
c
goes through e and keeps on going
forever so that would be ray c e
and you might say well and you can also
have a ray that starts at c goes in the
direction of f and goes on forever but
these are actually the same ray
these are actually the same ray because
f sits on ray c e and e sits on ray cf
remember the second point is really just
helping you specify the direction that
you're going to keep on going in forever
so these two are the same ray ce is
disarray that starts c and keeps on
going to the left forever cf is the ray
that starts at c and keeps on going to
the left forever so these two are the
same ray so they'll only count as one
ray
now let's go
let's think about what we can do from
point e well we can start at point e and
keep on and going the direction of c go
through c and keep going so that's array
you have ray e
c
you could start at point e and go in the
direction of a and keep going so that's
another ray
ray
e a
and you can start at point e and go in
the direction of f and keep going so
that is ray
that is ray ef and just to be clear ef
is different than cf because they're
starting at two different places they go
in the same direction they both go
through f but one is starting here and
one is starting right over there so
that's why those are different rays
now let's go to i'll pick do it in
orange let's think about what we can do
from point f
point f you might be tempted to go to
the left but there's no other point here
they haven't given us any other point to
specify this direction so let's think
about those to the right we could have
ray f e started f go through e and keep
on going so you could have ray
f e and then you might say well there's
also ray fc start at f go through go in
the direction of c go through c and keep
on going but that's the same thing as f
e
as f e
point c is on ray f e this is ray f e
right over here and e is on point on ray
f c so these are actually the same ray
and then finally we haven't looked we
haven't focused on a point a just yet
but you if we go you might say hey maybe
there's ray a e but we see the line
actually doesn't keep on going on and on
forever so that's not array and you
can't go keep on going to the top right
because there's no other point here to
specify the direction and so that's
about all we can do about finding the
rays given the points that have been
specified if they specified some more
points for example if they gave us a
point right over there we would have
been able to define other rays we could
have had this you know if this was point
g you could have ray gh you could have
had array ge you could have had ray gf
but they didn't give us that point and
if you had other points over here and
here and here you could have had those
rays that started f to the left h and h
going upwards a going to the top right
but they didn't specify so i'm guessing
that the way the question was written
they say identify all the rays that have
that that involve the blue points that
were given in the problem and if we
think about those there are 1 2 3 4 5 6
using those original blue points that
they gave us in the problem in only
those original blue points